ce sera fait
oh
c'est quoi tout le monde voit la la la
la la la la la non mais tu te tais toi
oh hé oh oh ça tape pas pourquoi tu est
active pourquoi tu ta qui vont pas
plonger
bah
c'est beau
c'est merveilleux mais
j'ai l'impression je vais me retrouver
en guyane
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
journée mondiale du rêve qu'il s'agisse
gérer les difficultés rendent là une
première
et vous avez vous déjà vécu vos rêves
est ce que vous vivez vos passions
pourquoi certains
réussissent
à faire ce qu'ils ont envie de faire et
d'autres n'y arrive pas
la vie avec toutes les difficultés que
j'ai rencontrées depuis le début jusqu'à
il ya peu de temps
m'a permis une chose très importante
il ne faut jamais baisser les bras
quoi qu'il arrive il faut avancer
tout est possible il faut oser
marqueurs cela
grands navigateurs
a eu un accident à l'âge de 30 ans
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé à ce brave
monsieur
il était en régate ils entouraient des
étudiants et la boum ce qui tient la
grand voile afin 180° l'injecter à l'eau
il est tombé dans le coma il s'est noyé
quand il s'est réveillé on lui a dit
vous êtes sourd donc sourd d'une oreille
et s'est rendu compte qu'il avait des
acouphènes mais le pire a été ce que le
médecin lui a dit vous avez perdu
l'équilibré plus jamais vous ne pourrez
monter sur un bateau imaginé c'est votre
passion et on nous dit c'est fini plus
jamais
eh bien vous savez quoi
depuis ce très cher marc il a fait 22
transatlantique cinq tours du monde dont
4 vendée globe
il est arrivé 4e et 2e d'ailleurs l'a
fait cet
figaro en solitaire 4 cap horn
et si je me souviens bien quatre tours
de l'antarctique ou ne ferai plus jamais
de bateaux
vous savez ce que fait le cerveau
le cerveau il a tendance à faire l'
inverse de ce qu on lui dit
tout à l'heure on parlait de fumer
je fume en faudrait que j'arrête de
fumer
du coup on tire mais je me prendrai une
clope
le cerveau va toujours faire la
différence
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans j'ai été
dispensés d'activité physique
et bat depuis je me suis bien rattrapé
vtt de descente descente en canyoning
rappel de 70 mètres de la voile du
changement passe est bonne et les
meilleurs tout ce qui a drainé line tous
qui truquent à sensation je suis dedans
pourquoi
en fait
m'est arrivé quelque chose qui m'a
marqué toute ma vie à 27 ans
j'ai perdu mes jumeaux quand j'étais
enceinte de six mois
et tout ce qu'elle avec pour pouvoir en
avoir d'autres un jour
alors je passe les détails mais trois
opérations en quinze jours dont de 8h à
chaque fois dont deux en 24 heures je
suis resté entre la vie et la mort
pendant un certain temps et il ya une
phrase aussi comme marc lui l'a vu sa
phrase moi j'ai la mienne vous ne vous
ne devriez pas être de ce monde
mais je pense que ça ça a favorisé le
fait que
attends je vais te montrer je vais vivre
tout ce que je veux vivre et je veux le
vivre
surtout que derrière du négatif il y a
toujours du positif ça qu'elle sait
quelque chose de très puissant le mental
est très puissant quand on veut on peut
si on ne le veut pas vraiment c'est
qu'on ne le désirent pas parce que le
cerveau va tout mettre en place
si vous vous dites un jour moi il ya
deux ans je rêvais de faire un thé l'x
et je suis là devant lui en fait le
cerveau va mettre en place tout ce que
vous lui dites j'aurais jamais mon
examen avant ça c'est sûr un des chances
de ne pas la voir
par contre si je vais y arriver un jour
je ferai ça un jour je le ferai
croyez en vos rêves croyez en ce que
vous voulez en vos projets il faut y
aller il faut foncer derrière il ya
toujours un bien devant chaque
difficulté il ya des cils il ya des
solutions
ma solution pour moi quand j'ai perdu
les bébés et que j'avais que je pouvais
plus en avoir et bien en fait ce qui a
fait que je m'en suis sorti ça a été
l'amour de mes proches et ils envie de
continuer à faire du sport et de voyager
j'adore les voyages j'ai plein de
passion j'en ai plein j'adore mais
j'évite je veux les quoi qu'il arrive je
garde toujours un petit temps pour vivre
ma passion quelle qu'elle soit est en
fait le bonheur que j'ai eu après cet
événement qui a été très durs dans la
vie c'était l'adoption
c'était pour un meilleur derrière vivre
l'adoption d'un petit bout ça a été mais
un bonheur immense
[Musique]
je vous souhaite à tous un jour si vous
avez des difficultés
voire de vous rendre compte que derrière
il ya toujours un bonheur et un plus
c'est du positif
ne pas regarder le négatif toujours voir
le côté positif des choses
alors pourquoi face à l'inconnu on a
peur
pourquoi lorsqu'on veut faire un nouveau
projet on a peur
pourquoi on a peur d'avancer face à
l'inconnu massé lui c'est tout
simplement lui il est bête et méchant en
fait
quand on m'a on a une on a en a
comment vous expliquez ça on a une
manière de pensée qui est automatique
il ya les gens ils vont vous dire on
attend mais tu y arriveras jamais
voiture m oui je rêve oui je rêve
turenne n'écoutez pas ces gens là parce
qu'en fait nous ne sommes pas tous câblé
de la même manière donc comme nous
sommes pas tous kappeler de la même
manière puisque nous réagissons en
fonction d'une situation on va la
prendre ou un mot on va le comprendre en
fonction de nos vécus dans nos cultures
de nos inversion de nos désirs
de tous qu'on est de tout ce qu on a
pris nos apprentissages
donc forcément vous vous réagissez face
une situation rêvée de faire un jour
telle ou telle chose et on vous dit
multi arrivera jamais ne les écoutez pas
pourquoi il vous dit ça parce que
eux-mêmes ne serait peut-être pas
capable de le faire
pourquoi écouter ces gens là écoutez
plutôt votre petite voix intérieure
écouter ce qu'ils y aillent au fonds de
vous et n'écoutez pas les autres tenez
compte de votre opinion à vous et
allez-y ça fonctionne je vous assure que
ça fonctionne
pourquoi ça fonctionne
notre cerveau est très complexe à 100
milliards de neurones connectés chacun
100 milliards de fois
ça fait un certain nombre de connexions
comment voulez-vous que deux personnes
sur une situation face une situation
réagissent de la même manière nous
imaginer une grosse boîte électrique
avec plein de câbles chaque câble à sa
connexion chacun des leçons à sa façon
de faire
pourquoi vous vous vous vous si je vous
mets
dans un avion et je vous dis sauter en
parachute
la vainqueure fille géniale et l'occupé
renommée était malade donc ça va non
mais ça va pas dans ma chair
en fait notre cerveau il a tendance à
marcher en mode automatique c'est quoi
le mode automatique il va reprendre tout
un tas de zone l'instinct de survie
individuelle etc
et face aux simples et reconnus il sait
faire mais face aux changements il a des
difficultés
il va falloir faire un effort face aux
difficultés face à la nouveauté il va
falloir passer en mode adaptatif qui se
situe dans notre cortex préfrontal
d'ailleurs les neuroscientifiques ont
bien vu que sur l'ir m les gens qui sont
dans la partie du cortex préfrontal
ne sont pas stressés
et cote quand ça s'allume derrière quand
on est stressé la salue sa ville soit
derrière soi devant mais ça ne peut pas
être les deux donc en fait face à une
nouveauté on va comme il faut faire un
effort et bien en fait le cerveau va
nous emmener en stress mais on devrait
stressés qu'en cas de danger de mort
immédiate pour construit sous les jours
c'est du stress qu'on se crée donc face
à la nouveauté on va rentrer dans le
stress parce que c'est la partie la plus
rapide du cerveau non pour sortir aussi
vite il suffit de repérer qu'on est en
stress pour se dire quelles sont les
solutions possibles il y a toujours des
solutions il ya toujours des solutions à
tous
donc quand vous serez en réflexion en
curiosité dans la créativité dans la
prise de recul dans la réflexion et dans
votre opinion personnelle vous êtes
salut au niveau du cortex préfrontal
et vous ne pourrez pas être un stress
donc quand vous êtes stressé suffit de
passer en mode adaptatif pour sortir du
stress parce que le stress rend non
performants le professeur gosselin a
fait une étude sur un quart de siècle
sur cinquante deux études qui montrent
que plus le stress augmente plus la
performance diminue dans la majorité des
cas dans 75% des cas la casse pour cent
des cas ces lits à rien du tout et il ya
seulement que dans 10 cursan des cas que
celle inverse
alors un exemple
récemment l'année dernière je fais une
randonnée en solitaire parce que j'ai
commencé la randonnée il ya deux ans vu
que je peux pas faire mes activités
autres
et là je monte je me retrouve sur un
chemin pas large
le vide à droite en haut ça montait des
rhododendrons dents quand on rentre dans
des rhododendrons peut se tordre et
libre
donc je vois pas un troupeau de vaches
arriver
et alors là le chemin l'ipa large pas si
vous le voyez on l'a la photo a été
prise au moment où elle avait commencé à
passer à droite à gauche
parce que fait l'animal en stress il va
toujours aller dans le même sens en
premier ses cuirs ci peut pas fuir il
attaque et si le prédateur est plus fort
que lui il va faire le mort des fois
qu'on oublie l'être humain c'est pareil
sauf que lui suivant les situations
soient en fuite en lutte ont une
émission d'actions
donc là forcément je suis rentré en dans
la peur ce que j'ai dit oui ils vont
écraser on se fait tout un film en un
dixième de seconde et je dis non faut
pas que tu aies peur parce que donc
comme j'ai pris l'habitude maintenant de
faire des petites alarme à chaque fois
que je sors ça je dis il faut que je
bascule
je bascule en mode adaptatif
corps y est arrivé tu fais un petit
passage en politique comme ça et puis
l'image qui passait à droite qui se
tordait les pattes on est passé à gauche
et se tordait les patrouilles et puis et
puis mais l'idée là et puis d'un seul
coup le taureau s'arrête devant moi il
tourne à tête il me regarde
alors là
non je n'ai pas peur je veux pas voir
peur donc en fait il va falloir comme
envers laisser passer les taureaux etc
et je dis mais pas ce vase il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas de problème tu peux tu peux
y aller n'a pas de problème et le
taureau est passée juste derrière
faisait le taureau il protéger la vache
qui arrive avec ses petits bouts tout
simplement
en fait tout est possible
face à une difficulté toute difficulté
de la nuit quelles qu'elles soient si
vous anticipez s'ils vivent ou
visualiser la situation
le serveur le prendra comme du connu
donc du coup vous pourrez pas être en ce
moment ça viendra si vous acceptez la
situation parce qu'on ne peut pas
changer une situation
vous serez dans le mode adaptatif en
plus si vous vous adapter à la situation
et si en plus derrière vous fait plaisir
comme à mon arrivée où le coeur battait
très fort si vous vous émerveillez vous
fait plaisir
la dopamine vab et la dopa une belle
montée et du coup ça vous enlèvera de
votre parti et du stress
je loue des voiliers dans le monde
entier alors sur un bâton que j'ai
assuré que les comportements
l'exploration comportementale là on la
voit mais l'or en plein parce que sur un
voilier dans un espace restreint comme
un voilier on ne peut pas faire comme
mon buzz décidé machin les comportements
là c'est automatique on va voir les gens
qui sont sociales on va voir le stress
des gens on va voir comment il se
comporte comme ans il s'adapte c'est un
lieu magique pour l'exploration
comportementale le bateau est là je peux
vous assurer que si j'anticipe pas la
partie ce qui peut en faire tant que
chef de bord si gentil si pas
si je m'adapte pas aux situations qui
est toujours un truc qui se passe sur un
bateau est toujours un truc qui va pas
et bien ce moment là
bas si moi je stresse les autres vous
êtes stressé par effet miroir
dernièrement je suis monté en montagne
première fois je prends mon bivouac en
solitaire tout était beau tout est bien
j'en ai sué pas possible à la montée
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya
une rage qui est arrivé
donc là stress j'ai horreur de leur âge
en montagne donc j'ai tout sécurisé j'ai
monté un petit mur j'ai bien rattacher
les attaches je suis passé par tous les
stress possible parce qu'à un moment
donné quand l'orage est arrivé je me
suis couché je vois des éclairs au parc
et et là j'ai dit nadal sort de ton
stress comment j'ai fait je me suis dit
écoute il peut rien t'arriver pas
renforcer les attaches tu as fait un
petit mur tu es loi des éboulis donc ça
va donc du coup voyez la manière dont on
peut réagir quand on est en strass en
fait c'est trouver les solutions
possibles et trouver qu'est ce que j'ai
fait qui fait que je ne peux pas il peut
rien m'arriver
une phrase que j'aime beaucoup de nelson
mandela j'ai appris que le courage n'est
pas l'absence de peur mais la capacité
de vaincre ce qui fait peur mais c'est
100% 50% vrai
donc laissé tomber les barrières laissez
les laisser tout ce qu'on vous dit
foncez dans vos projets
faites vous plaisir
n'attendez pas osé
vous savez quoi
et ben moi j'ose
jose parce que là parce qu'on fait
jamais ce que les autres aiment faire on
a toujours peur de faire différemment
d'être différent des autres donc moi
honnêtement là je vous dis de suite
si ça veut bien sortir alors je vous le
dis de suite
le vent souffle dans le bon sens n'est
ce pas donc le 25 octobre je vous laisse
j'ai ma transat ligue a préparé et je
vous dis à bientôt
[Applaudissements]